des blessés par les policiers également
lors de la manifestation de samedi
contre la proposition de loi sécurité
globale et parmi eux le photographe
indépendant d'origine syrienne à mers el
al albi ce dernier a reçu un coup de
matraque
installé en france depuis près de trois
ans l'homme de 24 ans encore sous le
choc ne décolère pas face à son
agression c'est à dire c'est que géo
l'image de la serre et il ne serait pas
le cas si on rentre lacérer le france
mais j'ai vécu la même situation a
empiré quand j'avais 15 ans dans une
manifestation que j'ai eu deux balles
dans le mans je ne travaille bloqué je
n'avais pas à servir aller à l'hôpital
ferme la manifestation est toujours dans
la rue ça ça me fait pas plus loin ça
m'a rendu fou à la der de voir l'image
de l'ep d'être apparaît vers la même
situation le cinquième partout je fais
jamais expliquer cela mais c'est dur
d'avoir une image d'aller tuer
apparaître la même situation
neuf ans plus tard c'est géré mon
travail je m'attendais pas